I understand in the world of
entertainment movies and video games
there's like a hundred things I could
talk about right now but I gotta talk
about this why because it's so absurdly
it's like comedy news Super Mario
Brothers 2 are some new Super Mario
Brothers 2 for the 3ds is holding up
tradition we're current gen consoles or
having side scroller Mario games because
at a point
everybody missed side scroller Mario
games so new Super Mario Brothers came
out for the DS and since then we've had
a few installments of side scroller
Mario games they just never go out of
style for the most part so new Super
Mario Brothers 2 gives you everything
you've come to love about side scroller
Mario for the most part you got
fireballs goombas turtle shells piranha
plants coming out of pipes secret coins
that are hidden every level has three
secret coins that you need to find it's
really familiar but at this point you're
like yeah it's so familiar it's it's
almost too familiar I mean they
reincorporated the leaf that gives you
the raccoon tail and the little raccoon
ears so they kind of already did that
when they reincorporated the Tanooki
suit in Super Mario 3d Land but that's
not even the part where you're like is
this worth playing right now it's the
fact that I saw the trailer and in the
trailer you see so many coins and that's
the theme in this game it's all about
the coin greed is good
apparently Mario is now a big Wall
Street fan but pipes spew out gold in
this game you hit these rings that turns
everything gold so you throw a turtle
shell it leaves a string of gold coins
you get that you get fireballs it just
turns [ __ ] into gold and you just gather
up the gold the back of the box even
challenges you can you collect a million
coins so you're thinking about it you're
like wait is this game still going on
the premise that every 100 coins is a
1up you get a free life yep in this game
it does that hold on doing the math so
did the game box just challenge you to
get 10,000 1ups
yeah it did the fact that the game box
is even challenging you to do that is
saying that it is a probability that
that could happen in which case the game
is the most broken Super Mario game
that's ever existed in my life but on
the off chance you miserably fail and
you don't even get close to that mark
like me I only got 50,000 coins in the
game yes that's right I only got 500
lives by the end there is no way you're
going to fail this game ever only reason
kind of infuriates me is like I get the
gimmick of like oh we want gold to be a
big thing in this game but it takes away
from any challenge of this Super Mario
game there's no way any human being
could fail at this game with 500
attempts to get it right any level that
really locks you up don't worry you're
gonna nail it before you hit the game
over screen in fact I would bet anything
no human being has ever seen the game
over screen in this game I have no idea
what it looks like neither do you
neither does anybody other than the fact
that the game really isn't that hard in
the level setup just it's not difficult
at all and just like Super Mario 3d Land
when you miserably fail and you die like
four times in a row it gives you that
little feather the one that turns you
gold and makes you invincible for the
entire duration of the level wait did
the game just tell me that it lacks
faith in me is like you know I don't
think that he can actually beat this
level within 500 attempts here's a free
gold feather go crazy Jeremy because we
think you suck I mean most the challenge
in this game like the Super Mario games
that have come from New Super Mario
Brothers on is finding the three hidden
gold coins in the levels finding the
secret exits that leads you to secret
levels that is actually challenging in
this game some of these things are
really well hidden I get it that's very
cool but even if it's really hard
sometimes you're like I just I don't get
it I don't know what does the game want
me to jump down every single pit seeing
which one has a gold coin maybe but
that's okay because you have 500 lives
by the end at least you will get it done
it just math says so I mean it's the
game fun yeah it's a Super Mario game
it's a fun casual game in the palm of
your hand that's always cool I'm it's
playing the really hard PC games or your
console games when you're at your work
you know you're at your job you have
your 3ds you're just trying to crack it
open when you're trying to be lazy
without your boss looking crack out a
couple levels find a few gold coins and
you know it's all good but in terms of
how Super Mario games go it is the
lowest of them everyone Super Mario
games were really tough like by the time
you were at the end of the game if you
had lives that were in the double digits
if you had more than ten lives you were
like a gaming god you only got there
because mega man taught you the
fortitude it took to beat a game now
gold coins spew out of pipes rain from
the sky bricks turn into gold the game
just gives it to you it's like hey here
here's God mode lack of challenge like
that just kind of makes the game feel
born so yes I think it's time for me to
have a
rating system for video games and I
think I've thought it up so first of all
the game is just just the greatest game
ever of course it's got to be awesome
tacular it's a staple you know it has to
be the best of the best in movies and
games next one down for video games is I
would buy it at full priced equivalent a
buy it on blu-ray it works alright
moving on I would buy it on sale the
games not quite worth buying it at full
price but if it takes a prize slash yeah
dump some cash on it why not the next
one worth a rental I'm thinking of
throwing in worth a rental if you have
no other games on your play not really
worth buying and if you do buy it you're
going to end up trading it in for store
credit for one tenth the retail price of
what it's actually worth so you might as
well just rent the game play through it
beat it and be done with it the next one
down the list is borrow it from your
friend for free after he paid for it
what are friends for what can I say this
is like alright your boards got nothing
to do borrow your friends copy of the
game play through it why not dump money
on it no for the lowest of the low I'm
kind of torn I'm thinking maybe I should
keep [ __ ] just because I like how it
sounds I'm thinking because it's games
may be game over would be a good one or
avoid it like the digital herpes that it
is or something I don't know if I play a
game that's completely terrible I will
probably it'll come to me odds are if I
hear a game is completely terrible and
probably not going to invest the time to
play cuz the fact is I'm a human being I
have dated a human being [ __ ] to do in
my life I don't have the time to invest
in things I know are terrible movies are
different they're like two hours you're
in and out games take many hours most of
the games that I'll take the time to go
through play and do a video on will
probably be in the rent it buy it or God
willing awesome tacular rating however
there is your gaming scale in the same
tradition of the movie rating scale I
don't even like writings and one of
those people where I'm like did you
listen to the review all right well then
you kind of know where I'm coming from
why do I need a rating but if you need a
rating there you go there's your rating
for games and this game would be rent it
if you have nothing else on your plate I
throw that last part in because there's
a lot of [ __ ] out there in the gaming
world it's a Mario game sure it's worth
a casual playthrough but worth buying
notes you're probably gonna end up
trading it in I see your favorite Super
Mario Brothers game what is your
favorite whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you